وفي تصحيح لافت من بيلاروسيا اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع البيلاروسيه انها تعمل مع قياده
شركه على اعداد خريطه طريق للمستقبل
القريب بشان التدريب ونقل الخبره لوحدات
القوات المسلحه وجاء في بيان الوزاره انها
تلقت طلبات مختلفه بشان نظام التدريب
المشترك لقوات المسلحه
ومقاتلر وكانت الدفاع البيلاروسيا قد
اوضحت في وقت سابق ان مقاتلين من شركه
فاجنر الروسيه العسكريه الخاصه يشاركون في
عمليات تدريب المطلوبين للخدمه العسكريه
والمشاركين في هذه الوحدات
معنى من وارسو دكتور عمر عاشور الاستاذ
دراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه دكتور عمر
هل هذا يعني ان دوره فاجنر في المرحله
المقبله سيقتصر على نقل الخبرات وتدريب
المنتسبين الجدد
ربما حتى الان غير واضح ربما هو اعلان
اعلان حكومي
بالاساسيه
ربما يكون
المقصود هو
اعداد
هم يريدون اعدادات كود احتياط هناك
شبيهه بقوات الاحتياط عند الاوكرانيين
يمكنها ان تقدم مثل هذه الخدمه نظرا
للخبرات المتراكمه ونظر لقدرتها على
القتال في في حروب المدن والخبرات التي
تراكمت سواء في غيرها
فربما يكون هذا احدى المخارج
لكن يبدو ان هناك عناصر اخرى موجوده في في
روسيا ويبدو ان بعضهم عرض عليهم ان ينضموا
داخل القوات المسلحه داخل الحرس الوطني
الروسي ده ليست القوات المسلحه لان
العلاقات الدفاع ليست جيده او بالقياده
وزاره الدفاع ليست جيده
فبالتالي يعني هذا يمكن يكون احدى المخارج
فقط لكن لها تداعيات بالتاكيد حينها تكون
متمركزه في بيلاروسيا والحدود قريبه من من
اوكرانيا وكذلك حدود اخرى مع بولندا
فهذه هذه التداعيات على الاقل سياسيه
وربما امنيه وعسكريه لاحقا على كل
الانضمام الى القوات المسلحه الروسيه هذا
الامر كما اشار الكرملين يعني دونه حتى
الان عواق عوائق قانونيه وبالتالي المساله
ربما تحتاج الى وقت اطول لكن فكره ان
مقاتلي فاغنر في بيلاروسيا يعملون على
تدريب وحدات بلا روسيا ومطلوبين للخدمه
بيلاروسيا ماذا تريد يعني ما الهدف من هذا
الاجراء
البيلاروسيه اساسا
ثلاثه امور جزء سياسي لانه
القياده البياروسيه تدخلت في اثناء هذه
المحاوله يعني ما سميناها تمرض مسلح
عصيان محاوله انقلاب هذه المحاوله
دخلت فيها كوصيد ما بين قياده
وعلى اساس
تستخدم
باقدر الى الروسيه ويكون لها دور هناك دور
ما غالبا اما في التدريب واما حتى في
الدفاع
فهذا الشق السياسي الشق العسكري هم هم
الذين هم خبرات حقيقيه يعني
القوات البيلاروسيه لم تدخل في معارك
كبيره
ولن لا يوجد لديها نفس خبرات هنا هذا هذا
ما اود ان اسالك عنه يعني ما هو دور
القوات هذه القوات التي يتم انشاؤها
وتدريبها القوات البيلاروس يه ماذا سيكون
دورها المستقبل لماذا الان يتم تدريبها
بهذا الشكل
لا هو ما اعلن عنه هو قوات احتياط قوات
الدفاع الابيض هذه قوات احتياط طبعا تجربه
قوات الاحتياط في في اوكرانيا كانت فريده
للغايه يعني من
اوقف الهجوم على بعض مناطق كيف كانت قوه
احتياط موجوده على الارض فكان لهم دور
فعال للغايه
دكتور عمر كان هناك في الفتره الماضيه
مخاوف من ان تنتقل تنطلق العمليات
العسكريه من داخل الاراضي بيلاروسيا عبر
مجموعه هل يمكن ان يكون الان هو ذات
المخطط ولكن بدل ان تكون عناصر يكون عناصر
مدربه من قبل
نعم هذا هو التحدي الامني الاخر الذي تخشى
منه كل من اوكرانيا وايضا بعض
المجاوره البيلاروسيا ان اما ان تقوم
باجنر او من تدربهم بتهديد عسكري ما ولكن
هو هو تهديد سيكون في حجم ليس بالكبير لان
القوات البيلاروسيه ليست
ليست لها عدد كبيره وليس لدي اختبارات
طويله يعني في المعارك ولكن هو تهديد يعني
الى حد ما تهديد موجود ومحتمل
او الامر الاخر ان تقوم باكثر ببعض
العمليات هي هو ايضا لها دور او خبره
طويله في اطار الحرب الهجينه
بما فيها الاختراقات بما فيها العمل
الاستخباري بما فيها البرتغاندا بما فيها
الاختراقات والعمل خلف خطوط العدو فلديها
خبرات مطوله في هذا الامور سواء في في
اوكرانيا او في في افريقيا كذلك
حتى الان شكرا جزيلا لك
الدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه